[Music]
i am cute as a button i don't care what
you people say online
all right happy thursday everyone and
what a glorious thursday it is
but sadly not for our dear friend the
president
according to the latest poll biden's
less popular than an anchovy with a
yeast infection
only 33 percent of adults approve of
biden's job performance which is a
record low and after answering the poll
those 33 percent were rushed back to the
mental health facility where the
pollsters had found them
but his approval is like his body
temperature barely above freezing it's
dropped three points since november and
it beats former president trump's worst
approval rating by one point
well at least he can finally say he's
better than trump at something but it is
an amazing comparison consider the kind
of press that trump got it was a
relentless drumbeat of hysterical hate
and yet joe who has none of that from
the press is rated worse than trump how
can that be
how is it that a genial old man coddled
by every media entity on earth is now
less popular than the monster the media
deemed worse than hitler stalin and
maroon 5 combined
[Laughter]
yes it's an amazing feat but not when
you see how bad
it's really gotten
vaccinated americans who are wondering
why they should continue to restrict
their activities given that your health
officials say most americans will get
coveted at some point
folks we'll talk about that later
[Music]
there we go oh he's praying for it all
to end
well that's about as reassuring as an
uber driver with whiskey on his breath
remember americans were sold joe as
polit political xanax after the crystal
meth of donald trump joe was supposed to
be beloved popular or relief from
captain evil
but even treated with kid gloves we
can't stand him even with the facelift
and the hair transplant you can't make
him look good why is that i mean other
than the fact he's a demented old circus
monkey well let's ask the president why
his numbers are so low
look look look people used to like me
all right
i i used to shake hands on the amtrak
i'd get in close and squeeze the
charmand that's what worked now i got to
do what they say and they told me
spend a year in the basement keep your
mouth shut when you come out you'll be
president
it worked
so i gotta do what they say
they won't even let me smell people's
heads anymore
you know i think jen sackey's hair
smells like cinnamon but i'll never know
that's the real tragedy
so the reasons for joe tanking in the
polls are obvious whenever crap is bad
which is a lot under the dems they don't
address it they can't address it instead
they pivot it's why ginsaki is always
circling back as coveted in crime and
inflation continue joe scampered into
the world of voting rights looking for
cover and because they become so
invested in identity politics and wokism
they don't know how to solve actual
problems anymore it's just pronouns
instead of policy they've become so good
at racial theatrics but they bomb when
it comes to helping out the average
american voter meanwhile joe embraced
rhetoric that was about as unifying as
alec baldwin showing up on the set of a
new western
well unified america against him i
suppose hell even his allies admit he
went too far
perhaps the president went a little too
far in his rhetoric but fundamental
principles and values at stake are very
very similar if he was trying to get
votes
it was not the vote getting speech
i think he gave where you're going to
hell speech
yeah
it was a you going to hell speech and
not even in a hand basket
fact is while america struggles with
serious stuff joe just labeled half of
americans once again is bigots racists
monsters thanks for the support joe and
he wonders why he has a son who used to
mistake parmesan cheese on the rug for
crack maybe joe was just the a-hole the
left tried to tell you trump was he
played the whose side are you on stick
until even his own side doesn't want to
be on his side anymore pretty soon no
one will be left to kidnap gretchen
whitmer
i mean when you lose al sharpton and
dick durbin you are on
island
and no one wants to get near you the
only way off is to swim right through it
so joe is calling everyone racist this
from a man who went to the funeral of a
kkk leader his own vp implied he was
racist during the debates
that's what the democrats have become a
bunch of people calling everyone else
racist including each other too bad they
can't tell you why you're racist just
like critical race theory you just are
but really joe whose voting rights are
americans denying they keep saying it's
jim crow on steroids but they can't find
any victims with giant foreheads and
back acne there's no evidence that
republicans have tried to stop a legal
voter from voting in fact it's kind of
the opposite i mean how did georgia a
red state that has a large black
population flipped blue in the last
election it sure wasn't because
republicans kept black people from the
ballot box
they can't even name one person kept
from voting is it a convicted murderer
who doesn't have a picture id i don't
know but then say so we need clarity of
who we're discriminating against for
god's sake and yet the media plays along
president biden's fight to protect
voting rights in this country president
biden has to win hearts and minds on
capitol hill when he visits tomorrow to
push voting rights legislation the
president was pushing for the senate to
change its filibuster rules to pass
voting rights legislation right now
there is little hope any republican in
the senate will vote in favor of any
voting rights bill
i'd call them tools but that implies
usefulness because even as they support
the president his numbers still tank and
theirs right along with his and that's
because no one likes to be demonized
well i do but that's on role playing
night
you know how hard it is to find red
latex
an extra small
but joe keeps smearing decent people who
are just minding their own business they
aren't hindering the rights of others
when it comes to voting they're just
trying to get along in tough times it's
kind of amazing we're going through all
of this and joe's still out in front
calling you names while wondering why
everyone keeps calling him brandon i
mean we have a president who ran on
unifying but now all he does is yell at
you even though everything he accuses
you of like supporting bigots he
actually did himself so no wonder his
numbers continue to slide like a rectal
thermometer dipped in motor oil
yeah i know
at this space he may get his own show on
cnn
welcome tonight's guest she went from
president of now to independent wow fox
news contributor tammy bruce
he's running for new york governor
harder than the women who ran from our
last governor
congressman and republican candidate for
new york governor lee zeldin
yeah
he must have left his tiger in the green
room
what's up siegfried
yeah his wardrobe can induce seizures
fox across america host jimmy fayla
and she's like a kitchen sponge small
abrasive and far more disgusting than
most people realize
fox's contributor cat time
it looked like you mugged david blaine
this time
are you gonna do a little house magic
during the break listen i love that
you're always begging on my clothes
you're wearing velcro shoes like do they
light up when you walk they'll grow
shoes are the greatest thing when you're
in a hurry slide them on in and shoelace
is in in stylish shoes shoelaces always
come loose do you ever notice that no
that isn't it
it's like that's you have one job
shoelace you have one job shoelace and
you remain untied it drives me crazy
it's absolutely nuts i think it's the
fault of big shoelace anyway
no as a bigot and a racist jimmy do you
get
you get offended
by the way did you notice how i didn't
push back
but did you you must get infected that
you know biden labels people that so
easily when you really have to work hard
to be a bigot in a race yeah time was
you had to get out there in your taxi
and refuse certain fares yeah idea then
you can just you know get it now for
not supporting a garbage voter rights
bill
shame on him yeah and of course it's
divisive and disgusting and inaccurate
but what's really like so disqualifying
about it is how stupid it is and what i
mean by how stupid it is is i mean the
strategic gambit of this the georgia
bulldogs on monday night won their first
national title in 40 years 40 years okay
they're football yes they're in the
middle of the biggest keg party america
has ever seen yeah somebody was like
i've got it we'll fly down an old man to
plug in his teleprompter and call
everyone racist it'll be great and
everybody's like who the hell let this
angry grandpa into the room right that's
true and it drives people crazy for two
reasons obviously the timing the
execution is bad but what georgia has
more early voting than delaware does
okay then most uh blue states do and
it's something even jake tapper called
out on cnn he said oh by the way how
come they never call out the blue states
with restrictive voting rights right and
to be clear georgia has no restriction
voting rights yeah there is no case of
somebody not being allowed to vote
although at this point the only thing
they're voting on is like what barter
hit next because they don't care but the
reason we're hearing these stories now
about hillary clinton potentially
running in 2024 one is because she's
probably paying doug shown to write the
article but two stick with me i mean she
wants it in the news but two it's
because we have already entered garbage
time in this presidency you know like in
a football game sometimes the team goes
up 31-0 in the first quarter and the
announcers are like what are we going to
talk about now well we're in that moment
in a presidency where the announcers are
like i guess we'll talk about hillary i
don't know and some people are like oh
no it's because she's younger than biden
so is moses that's not what we're
talking about
we're talking about her because he sucks
all right you're returning to your ear
as a cab driver you won't shut up thank
you just get me to 31st and third
uh hold on hold on let me get the kid
seat out of the back
love you yes uh tammy yes
okay his pulling numbers i didn't i
always i always thought that he would be
kind of likeable right when we did
weren't we supposed to think that he
well he's not going to be like trump
he's not going to be divisive he's more
divisive than trump it's amazing well i
think when people look back now trump is
a comedian yeah he realized his sense of
humor
and you needed the perspective right the
juxtaposition of this guy who is
generally screaming all the time get off
my lawn right he comes out he says get
off my lawn and when he was in the
basement we could project on to him
right he could be what we all imagined
like our grandpas or the old guy that we
do like and now he sits there and like
with that clip you had he doesn't just
sit there and look confused he smirks at
you yeah like he knows the secret and he
thinks you're dumb right and he's the
problem yeah so that's where americans
are looking like you know this isn't
even like oh theoretical arguments or
about immigration even though it is it's
real life events that we see now every
day like we can't fill up the gas tank
because it's too expensive or it's like
do i buy my kids or my husband a steak
or do i fill up the the tank you
everybody by the stake yeah but yeah i
mean you it's you have to you you can't
avoid it every day and here's this guy
sitting there like we're the problem and
like he knows everything and then he's
smirking at people and it the american
people they don't like bullies they
don't like a people who look down on you
we love the underdogs we which this
show's doing so well people love the
underdogs right i mean so that's because
i'm good-looking well there you go
and you and you have a good time and you
people might disagree with you sometimes
but you're not talking down to the
people who i can't talk down to anybody
well there you go you know uh as i'm
short okay just to make that clear
congressman um it is kind of interesting
i i just like the fact that
like imagine if he had the same level of
media criticism
he wouldn't even be president anymore
his approval rating would be running
neck and neck with covid itself and
inflation yeah that's true now we should
not be shocked by these poll numbers
that we're seeing there's a lot of
crises from afghanistan southern border
and spending and inflation and supply
chain crises so we're not surprised by
this but this is how bad it's gotten ron
klain the white house chief of staff
just tweeted out an approval poll where
the disapproval was higher he was
underwater right it's gotten so bad
inside the white house that they're
pushing out bad polls like saying no no
i know it's bad but it's not that bad
things are not going well right now in
this country and it is uh important for
us to have competency but i think what's
actually frustrating a lot of americans
is worse than
incompetency is when you see policies
where you know exactly what you're doing
wrong and you do it anyway yeah and the
southern border that's that's not
incompetency they know what they're
doing wrong yeah and they do they
because they can't be seen to agree with
the people that they're already
demonizing right because the people that
know how to fix the border are the same
people that they're calling
deplorables or racists or cat timps
yes nobody calls me
i think i kind of can relate to the
mistake that he's making actually i
think everybody can i think what he's
doing is he's trying so desperately to
be liked by people that are never gonna
like him anyway right like the super
progressives they're never gonna like
you know the kkk eulogy guy you're never
gonna like the 1994 crime bill guy but
he tried to give a speech that only
those people would like right and then
and you know at the same time he's
turning away people that might be into
him
you want to put it but that's how you
end up with 33 approval rating he's
trying focusing so hard it's never going
to work anyway and he's just further
dividing at people and he's making
people not like him even more he's just
creating new problems which i think we
have enough problems already yeah he's
like he's on a date but he's checking
out the girl at the other table who
doesn't want to have anything to do with
them
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else